prenez déjà comment va comment va votre
maman déjà vraiment ma survienne
m'appeler le docteur est passé pour y
mettre une minerve parce que maintenant
là le contrecoup elle doit passer encore
des examens de la tête et
puis voilà il y a qu'à voir un cadeau
c'est pas possible le truc comme ça
c'est
sûr votre fils
je sais pas moi déjà j'aurais même pas
eu le courage de monter comme vous si
c'était mon fils
de la de la honte de du geste du coup
qui mais c'est pour tuer c'est pas pour
agresser piqué un sac [ __ ] à 80 ans
vous avez même pas besoin de la
bousculer vous prenez le sac ou le
prenez le sac c'est parti mettre un coup
comme ça malheureusement c'est pas
pardonnable c'est pas pardonnable je
suis désolé je comprends très bien que
ça vous crée des problèmes
si votre fils et puis ça vous crée des
problèmes pour la pour le travail pour
tout mais je suis désolé